Now, I want to point
something out to you Rory.
For most of this interview,
you've been looking sort
of slightly away from me.
Yeah.
And I think it's probably
because of where your
camera is or something.
Yeah.
But I'm telling you that
it makes you look untrustworthy.
I--
For most of the interview,
you've been going, "I really
enjoy working with you Conan."
And it's that weird--
I--
Sociopathic--
I was reading the cue cards
of the person you hired to come over here.
You think I wanna say "hot stuff?"
I was told I had to say
that or the interview--
There's no cue card!
Ends!
There's no cue cards! I'm
over here! (snaps and yells)
That's not even-- and
just for the listeners,
that's not a real guitar.
That's a green screen behind him.
His basement is worse than mine.
You're not looking at me!
Why are you not looking at me?!
The Zoom thing is so hard to figure out!
I wanna look at you--
No everyone else!
But then I'm looking up here!
I'm right here! Everyone
else is able to do it.
Where?!
You--
Conan?!
(Conan laughs)
Where?! Conan?!
This is you the whole interview,
"I uh, I want to tell you something Conan,
and I mean this from
the bottom of my heart."
What is that? What is that? What is that?
Well, I have the screen over here of you,
so I'm trying to see you
but I should be looking at
the camera that's up here
so then I can only sort of see--
Look, everyone watching this right now,
they all know the Zoom deal.
If you don't know the Zoom
deal by now, what's going on?
You know the Zoom deal.
You're over here. I gotta look here.
It's not right. It's not right.
OK, OK. Now listen to me.
We have a lot to talk about
and I'm glad to finally see your eyes.
It's nice. You're a handsome fellow.
You're a good looking guy.
You mean that?
Because I have not had a haircut
in about five months and--
Oh really? Because I'm getting
my hair cut constantly.
You look good. You really do look good.
You know what I find--
I guess I have to say that
without even looking over
to see if I truly believe it
cause I have to keep my eyes--
(Conan laughs)
On this camera.
Here's me seeing if I think it.
(grunts) Yeah, I like it.
You were like, "No, you
look good! Huh? Ew!"
(Rory laughs)